if you have a problem if no one else can
help and if you can find them maybe you
can hire the a-team
you had a great day okay
they walk the halls of Parliament in
their hundreds but just what does it
take to be an official accredited
assistant to one 751 any Peas at the
European Parliament I enjoyed this
it's a day-to-day learning process
without the wish now you are always
outputting consequently you need a team
and it's a team that you must be a good
team we can start with some chocolate
for breakfast it's all been seven years
ago I was 25 years old years I was
studying for doing other things in Italy
to become a judge but then I have this
opportunity to come here so I'm very
active seven years to say that was the
right choice for me it's not quite the
crack of dawn great day for the
assistants is early doors to prepare for
the day ahead but first things first we
gotta have a office meeting but it roses
we can have a coffee
we have like four minutes three minutes
with the three minutes up meetings
continue in the corridors yogi is a
30-something Hungarian assistant to his
poached by his NP and brought to
Brussels after he stood as a candidate
himself in the 2014 new elections he
deals with the environment Agricultural
Policy as a socialist meat also to
members the European People's Party
across various parliamentary committees
Caramella subs for her deputy the chair
of the Environment Committee he was
unable to attend all because knows well
coming because she is very happy when
she flexible when she has to be
flexibility standing in for the boss the
job of the assistant needs a
jack-of-all-trades someone who works
fast write speeches researchers
organized meetings and the list goes on
Italian is my mother thong and then
English and French English German and
studying French and of course I'm
speaking Hungarian work under stress so
you have to have a bit of multitasking
skill you have to be able to work in a
team Carmela is one of the two
accredited assistants based in Brussels
for her MEP in your keys office there
are three so just how many assistants is
too much MEP scan staff their offices at
their discretion as long as it falls
within parliamentary rules there's no
salary piece who have only one
assistants here at least 50 or 60
percent added value for an MEP fee as
she has a good group but back to the
meetings for your gates a quick coffee
to discuss environmental issues outside
the Parliament is a working lunch for
Carmela for both the systems a working
lunch is part of a typical day in theory
the working hours is starting from 9:00
until last till 6 o'clock but
in practice we are always available when
yummy busier it's rushing all day
basically maybe we don't have lunch and
then you finish a time when the MEP is
not here then you have more time but
then you maybe walk more so do you think
you have what it takes to join the 18
applications can be made directly to any
Peas check their website for further
details